Biden expected to take a Victory lap and
boast about how wonderful of a job he's
done during tomorrow's State of the
Union
here's just a little preview of The
Coming Attractions
try taking blame inflation no why not
because it was already there when I got
here man remember what the economy was
like when I got here
jobs were hemorrhaging inflation was
Rising we weren't manufacturing a damn
thing here we were in real economic
difficulty that's why I don't
an economy a record number of Americans
41 percent say they're financially worse
off since the big guy came into office
except maybe Hunter and his booming art
business and with numbers that bad the
spin meisters in the administration are
having a tough time watch as mayor Pete
struggles to list any Biden
accomplishments
let's go to the president's State of the
Union
look he's got a lot of things to tell
why do you think that it has not
penetrated the American public well
these things don't sell themselves and
it's one of the reasons I'm really
looking forward to that that State of
the Union Address I will say that there
have been so many accomplishments under
this Administration it can be difficult
to list them in a distilled way
it's like
a woman asks you you know
since I can't even list but where to
begin
that never happens to me no never uh he
says inflation is already here it was
already here that's like starting a
seven alarm fire and then saying well
there was a Dura flame already in the
fireplace so this is ridiculous and it
just I mean the only people apparently
they're doing well in the Biden economy
is Biden's family yeah I mean it's
amazing it is incredible I guess like
they're not going to say who's buying
these half a million dollar paintings I
don't blame them because it probably is
somebody unsavory but he's Chinese yeah
he's very lucky Biden presidency came
about at the perfect time we have a
frantically distracted population and if
this if he was if he became president in
the 80s and the 70s when I think he
tried to run it would it would have been
even more of a disaster because there
were fewer cheaper escapes from your
daily trials uh uh if you could say oh
my God these eggs cost a lot but then
you can go back to scrolling on Tick
Tock or popping in edible uh and it's
not so bad we've made so much progress
in society in terms of tech and Leisure
that a recession is actually less felt
because we've numbed ourselves we've
numbed ourselves against so much misery
that maybe we'll just endure it it's
kind of sad but it's also progress
things are so bad that Greg's Edibles
now cost less than a dozen eggs that's
amazing
can you
an omelette with edible I would not
tomorrow well I think there's been a
flurry of bad polling for the Biden team
even though they don't like to admit it
in fact today Brian deese who's on his
way out as economic director there he
said that the ABC polls showed that
two-thirds of Americans said that
circumstances are better that's not what
that poll said 16 1 6 percent of people
said that their circumstances are better
and what mayor Pete just said was well
we just have to communicate better it is
not a Communications problem and I think
what you'll see is tomorrow night it's
like when you tell an angry woman to
calm down how does that go down not well
and when you tell somebody to cheer up
no it just makes them more mad and this
is a feeling women right Dana
so you can just smile more right I know
turn that frown upside down lady and
then they just get more mad so I think
that you'll hear a little bit of that
tomorrow night that everything's great
low look no look we have all the jobs no
like no we actually do have all the jobs
people have two or three jobs people are
coming from the pandemic they just there
is a feeling in the country that they
just do not feel it and now what Bill
Clinton did at his point in the
presidency but remember he said I feel
your pain I get it I hear you don't
think you're going to hear that tomorrow
night because they are talking about how
great things are and they are going to
try to draw a contrast immediately this
is not just a state of the union speech
I think that this will be like the
anchor for the 2024 re-election effort
and I wouldn't be surprised if during
this Unity speech he decides to say that
if you look at the Republicans they're
the ones who want to take away your
Social Security they're the ones that
want to take away your Medicare they're
the ones this that and the other thing
and it's going to come off pretty badly
for some people some people might like
it
um must be kind of hard to be him though
right because there's stories that the
economy had better jobs numbers but his
vice president gets terrible headlines
again in the New York in the New York
Times today
it was saying basically saying that gosh
no one thinks she's doing a great job
there's only two stories for uh for
Kamala Harris it's either she screwed up
or that everybody thinks she's about to
screw up like there's just no other
choices and he's feeling though like
he's done all these great things and yet
most people the majority of Democrats
don't want Biden to run again but
tomorrow night will be the precursor to
his re-election speech why hasn't he
been able to emotionally connect with
the country she mentioned Bill Clinton
Biden was always supposed to be the guy
that was like feeling your pain Regular
Joe
why can't he say yeah this is tough and
acknowledge that
well he did he won in 2020 because he
was the guy that said that right he was
empathy Joe talking about what's going
on as covet is pillaging the country
people are losing their jobs their loved
ones Etc and if we recall the midterms
not that long ago his numbers were also
terrible around that and Democrats have
one of the best performance of the ad
since the 1930s or a first-term
president so I'm not at all convinced
that if we had the midterms again
tomorrow that we wouldn't have the same
results and that people can say I I feel
like I'm not better off I think the
economy is in the in the dumper or
whatever and I prefer the Democrats to
the Republicans I don't know we don't
have an election tomorrow well we would
have known about the classified
documents at the Penn Biden Center okay
maybe and and Mike Pence by the way is
getting a visit from the FBI for his
documents that's new to add to the pile
there
it's not about the documents
the frustration that the administration
feels in terms of these accomplishments
and there are real accomplishments you
want to talk about China the chips Act
is something that really if you want to
piss off Xi Jinping take away his
semiconductor business and that's what
the Biden Administration did so you have
that you have bipartisan gun reform that
had never happened we had five-year-olds
slaughtered in Sandy Hook we couldn't
get gun reform he got that done you have
the infrastructure Bill people are
getting hundreds of millions into rural
Broadband that will change the lives of
people the investment in hbcus now we
have insulin capped at 35 a month it's a
state of the union I'm trying I'm trying
well do you like it is
how are you going to be watching at the
edge of yourself tax credits I you know
what I'm I'm gonna time myself and see
how long I can last listening to him
first of all 62 percent of Americans
think that Joe Biden hasn't accomplished
very much so you know you can have uh
you know Jessica you can say X Y and Z
and I really think the reason that he
came through in the midterms that the
that the Democrats did I think it was
all about abortion abortion abortion
abortion and I don't think it was a
testament to how great Joe Biden is the
truth is 71 of the country thinks we're
on the wrong track people can't afford
food food anymore only 31 percent of the
country thinks the man is competent they
think he's incompetent and if you don't
think this this so-called balloon which
is a euphemism for a Chinese spycraft if
you don't think that impacts Americans
in a very unusual way we're not used to
them being over our land this is the
Homeland this is America they're now
buying millions of Acres near these
intercontinental ballistic missile sites
so that they can what grow corn and then
have an impact on our food supply it's
not what we think it is I really believe
that you know Americans recognize
inflation isn't transitory uh that he
surrendered to the Taliban and that all
of the bad stuff if they can at least
bring it out in terms of the fentanyl
crisis the southern border what's going
on in the air and the Border you know
they don't want someone said this they
don't want cheap talking points they
want something that reflects who they
are As Americans and how they can
survive in the next few years that's all
all right and you'll be doing some live
commentary tomorrow for the State of the
Union be there with our group okay we'll
be hearing uh at the table while you're
in DC yeah we're not allowed to travel
yeah I'd probably be sitting there um
yet uh we're thinking about getting some
animals from the Columbus Zoo okay we
gotta go I want to Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now